Karachi language Grandpa here again I'm
constantly reading up on how the brain
learns things because link essentially
caters to how we learn things and I
found an article in German it had a lot
of unknown words in it and I want to
show you how I deal with that situation
I found this very interesting PDF file
on how the brain learns but it was in
German and it had a lot of words that I
didn't know so what I did was import and
ebook and grab the file put it here
and then imported it into link for me
and then I went through the lesson
saving all the words that I didn't know
and when I completed the lesson not only
had I learned a lot about my brain but I
added 274 known words that I already
knew and I found another 115 new words
that I looked up and I'm in the process
of learning